[Musique]
en 2013 je suis devant ma télé le
journal de france 2 20 heures il y as
reportage sur la discipline positive la
discipline positive débarque en france
la discipline positif c'est une approche
éducative qui repose sur l'encouragement
comment encourager son enfant pour le
faire grandir
pour gagner pour qu'il puisse gagner en
confiance alors ça m'intéresse parce que
je cherche à créer du lien entre des
enfants et des parents
je fonce et avec le pragmatisme des
états unis ce sont des cours des cours
d'éducation des ateliers en pratique
beaucoup d'activités interactives ont
fait des jeux de rôle on joue les
enfants où jouent les parents
j'ai emmené mon mari évidemment parce
que c'est aussi pour notre famille et
puis je suis là je me sens bien
et la première chose qu'on nous pose
comme question un dispositif quand on
termine une activité c'est qu'est ce que
tu ressens
qu'est ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de
toi alors le ressenti est évidemment il
est intérieure mais il peut aussi se
traduire par des attitudes et des
postures
la première chose aussi qu'on nous dit
après le premier atelier le premier de
voir qu'on nous donne c'est d'observer
un enfant on prend rarement rarement le
temps et observer d'observer son enfant
alors je sors de là et d'atelier en
atelier je découvre tous ces outils de
l'encouragement ces outils qui nous
permettent de créer des liens entre les
enfants et les parents
et puis je deviens prof
oui je me forme et je deviens formatrice
en discipline positive alors à mon tour
j'anime des ateliers et lors d'une
activité avec une participante on parle
de l' écoute active
vous savez quand on ouvre grand ses
oreilles qu'on laisse nos téléphones
portables dans nos poches
condé dit tout notre corps et toute
notre attention à celui qui est en face
d'eux et sept participantes me dis pour
toi ça a l'air drôlement simple et ça
ressemble drôlement à ce que tu fais
avec des chevaux oui parce que ce que je
ne faisais pas dit c'est que mon premier
dada c'est le jeu
ma première passion c'est le cheval
alors évidemment le cheval je tombé
dedans depuis que je suis toute petite
j'ai trois ans des petites bottes
pointures 25 et je rentre dans le monde
des chevaux
je rentre dans le monde des poneys tout
d'abord ce sont des animaux imposant
impressionnant ils sont costauds
je suis tout petit mais ils sont aussi
très doux très accueillants bienveillant
et je vais grandir à côté d'eux ils vont
aussi m'accueillir sans leur jugement
ils vont motorisés à être moi même
imparfaite bavarde émotif fragile et il
va devenir un confident alors je grandis
la passion me poursuit je reste
cavalière et aujourd'hui je vis un rêve
éveillé puisque j'ai allier deux
passions la transmission l'enseignement
et le cheval je dirige un centre
équestre avec mon mari et j'accueille
des tout petits bébés cavaliers des
enfants des parents des adultes qui ont
envie d'aller dans la relation avec ce
cheval
qu'est ce qu'il a à nous apporter ce
cheval il l'a à nous apporter toute la
communication non verbale
parce que oui pour être en lien avec
l'autre il faut savoir communiquer et la
première chose avec le cheval c'est
qu'il ne parle pas quand vous rentrez
dans le pré des chevaux on va rentrer
dans une écurie
la première impression
la première chose que vous pouvez noter
c'est ce silence il est impressionnant
il ne reposant il est inspirant alors le
cheval c'est un animal dans la nature
c'est un herbivore il vit en troupeau
pour bien grandir il a besoin
d'interaction sociale
il va avoir besoin d'un leader ce leader
va être là pour le protéger lui donner
des alertes
le cheval va éveiller tous ses sens
sa sensibilité à l'environnement pour
pouvoir communiquer et il va faire
confiance à ce leader qui va lui
indiquer un danger qui va lui indiquer
s'il faut fuir
parce que la seule chose qu ici très
bien faire c'est fuir
il est curieux bienveillant mais s'il ya
danger il va fuir alors en quoi ça nous
intéresse mais nous humains nous sommes
on n'est pas herbivores nous ne sommes
pas une proie nous sommes des prédateurs
et ça c'est important parce que pour
tisser un lien avec le cheval il va
falloir gommer cette attitude de
prédateurs il y a jean françois pignon
un dresseur de chevaux en spectacle il a
plusieurs chevaux en liberté qui dit que
pour un homme auprès des chevaux il faut
être fort calme est rempli d'amour fort
remplie d'amour la discipline positive
elle nous invite à cette fermeté et à
cette bienveillance parce que la fermeté
solis vers l'obéissance et la force et
la bienveillance seul glisse vers la
permissivité et ce cheval va nous
inviter aussi à trouver l'équilibré
force est amour fermeté bienveillance et
au milieu de ça on va trouver du calme
parce qu'encore une fois le cheval ne
parle pas et c'est dans le silence qu'on
obtiendra les meilleures performances
alors il va falloir être fort pour le
protéger il va falloir être remplie
d'amour pour gommer notre attitude de
prédateurs auprès de lui alors
aujourd'hui
j'exerce dans mon centre équestre et
j'accueille des cavaliers très différent
et j'ai une jument que j'affectionne
beaucoup cette jument elle s'appelle
freya c'est une jolie blonde elle est
pas bien grande mais elle a un
tempérament très affirmée elle m'amuse
beaucoup parce qu'elle a toujours dans
sa tête l'idée de retourner dans son
prix elle est très assurée c'est la
jument leader dans le troupeau et elle
se dit sujet un timide un peu mon
cavalier quand il va me brosser je vais
peut-être tourné au près et on va en
prendre un autre
et moi j'observe quand je la confie à un
cavalier
j'ai plusieurs profils le premier il va
essayer une fois il va se reculer et
gagner en confort et se mettre en
sécurité très discrètement il va arrêter
de la brosse et papoter avec d'autres et
il va arrêter son job le deuxième va
essayer avec beaucoup de douceur
peut-être trop de douceur sans groen
convictions et à chaque fois que là je
m'en bat tourner la tête pour
l'intimider il va reculer d'un pas lui
également le troisième va élever sa voix
il va prendre une grosse voix il va
peut-être même taper sur le cheval pour
imposer sa force mais il lui manque
cette dose d'amour ces trois personnes
l'avons souvent venir me voir en disant
que ma jument est méchante mais je
demandais pas méchante elle est
simplement le miroir de leur équilibre
fermeté bienveillant et évidemment j'ai
aussi des cavaliers débutants confirmés
qui arrive près de cette jument et qui
ont un équilibre assez juste de cette
fermeté et de sa bienveillance et ça se
passe très bien à côté d'elle il y a
beaucoup de choses géniales chez les
chevaux une chose qui m'amuse beaucoup
c'est leur subtilité de langage corporel
ils peuvent bouger leurs oreilles 180°
s'achève je vais jamais arrivé vous non
plus mais d'autres choses qui sont
extras et c'est des vrais véritable
scanner de notre corps de notre esprit
ils vont venir chercher votre énergie
ils vont venir chercher vos émotions vos
intentions faute détermination et
ensuite ils vont également scanner votre
corps est ce que le corps correspond à
cette attitude à cet esprit ses émotions
que je viens d'analyser la dernière
chose que j'aime beaucoup c'est le
cheval c'est cet effet miroir c'est le
reflet qu'il nous offre de nous-mêmes et
cet accueil sans jugement c'est un
terrain juste formidable
vous avez un partenaire de jeu qui vous
offre votre propre reflet mais qui ne
vous juge pas croyez moi chez nos pères
c'est difficile à trouver mais chez le
cheval
vous avez un terrain d'exercice
extraordinaire alors il ya plein plein
de jeux pour justement comprendre
comment le cheval vient l'iran nous ces
informations il via l'iran nous ces
informations
dans notre tête et dans notre corps je
me souviens d'une fois
j'accueillais une classe de 6ème une
cohésion ils passent une semaine dans
notre centre équestre
ils viennent de paris autant vous dire
que les chevaux isab à peu près à quoi
ça ressemble parce qu'ils en ont lu dans
leurs comptes
enfin on leur a donné des images mais
l'animal ils ne connaissent pas bien ils
le voient comme un animal de 400 kg très
imposant qui peut mordre et marcher sur
leurs pieds on est dans la carrière à
n'est ce pas s'ensabler on march
simplement à côté son cheval le premier
exercice ces deux marchés de s'arrêter
et l'exercice que je leur demande se
joue avec un feu rouge feu vert ce verbe
marché feu rouge vous vous arrêtez
globalement autour de moi ça bouge
ils ont une longe et il marche à côté de
leur cheval
il s'arrête mais j'observe quand même
quelques duos en difficulté j'en ai un
qui regarde son cheval et qui dirige
vient bien si tu devais aller bien et à
chaque fois que le cheval va faire un
pas il va recul j'ai un autre duo qui en
difficulté parce que le cheval a trouvé
un brin d'herbe de l'autre côté de la
barrière et alors là il tire de toutes
ses forces et le cavalier tir de tourtes
s'efforce aussi je vous rappelle que
cheval fait 400 kg et qu'on en fait 50
c'est compliqué alors cela et tous les
autres je leur demande de se mettre en
cercle autour de moi et je leur demande
où vous allez où allez-vous et la
plupart me répondre là vous savez où ils
vont moi non plus et le cheval ne le
sait pas il ya un chuchoteur un cow boy
s'appelle rennes qui dit simplement et
très humblement le cheval c'est quand
vous savez mais il sait quand vous ne
savez pas alors je demande à nouveau à
mes petits cavaliers de me dire où ils
vont aller avec précision avec des
tailles et de lever le bras quand ils
m'ont quand ils sentent que ça c'est
précis dans leurs têtes alors un à un
ils lèvent leurs bras pour indiquer
derrière le plot orange derrière la
barre et y est devant moi
près du plô jaune et la jordi feu vert
qu'est ce qui se passe tout le monde
avance le cheval est venu chercher cette
information dans nos têtes il est venu
scanner notre détermination scanner
notre émotion on ait affirmé
on sait exactement ce qu'on a envie de
faire alors on se déplace et notre corps
notre corps vient traduire notre
détermination et notre énergie
intérieure c'est accessible à tous c'est
la magie des chevaux les enfants comme
les adultes ressortent de la grandi
parce qu'on gagne en confiance avec cet
animal c'est un animal qui est très
imposant et on sent assez puissant quand
on arrive à faire des choses aux
pralines
alors oui ce cheval est génial il aa
pouvoir des scanners esprit corps il va
vous apprendre à reprendre confiance en
vous et il n'est pas rare d'observer
dans ses séances des personnes anxieuses
retrouver du calme des personnes
stressées retrouver des rôles du
rattachement des personnes colérique
retrouver le contrôle d'eux mêmes des
personnes un peu égoïste qui développent
de l'empathie et celles qui sont très
affirmée vont aussi s'ouvrir ouvrir leur
esprit se remettre en question alors oui
aujourd'hui ce cheval vous offre toute
sa puissance pour développer la
communication non verbale
il vous offre son votre reflet par effet
miroir il va venir gonfler votre
confiance gonflée votre image de vous
même et vous aider à corriger cet
équilibre ferme éthier bienveillance
force amour alors beaucoup vont à des
conférences beaucoup lisent des livres
sur le dépassement personnel le
développement personnel la confiance en
soi voir ce que je vous propose c'est de
faire l'expérience du cheval licques et
des jolies phrases sur facebook si vous
souhaitez mais venez vous mettre en
action venez faire l'expérience du
cheval et je vous souhaite à tous de
manière ponctuelle ou régulière de
mettre un peu de cheval dans votre vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]